[Music]
congratulations on all your nominations
thank you thank you very much quite a
few it's been a magical year ripcord has
been a magical album and sped to be back
at the ICMS always performing with Julia
Michaels tonight I'm so happy she came
and wanted to do it alive tonight
wouldn't you do collaborations they're
always some of the best collaborations
what is it that worked about you guys
well you see the ones that work they all
work
don't they know I just I love everybody
it's it's just something everybody's
gonna bring out something different
artistically and I just love the
unexpected you have one backup singer
who is my absolute favorite backup
singer of yours all-time how did that
all come about and are we gonna see more
no no that's just like I was in the
house and he was doing he was recording
and he said hey baby will you come down
and sing a little bit and it was that
you know he has a studio in the house
yeah it was the right song it's the
right song yeah but I think you could
include her more because we liked it if
she's up for it she's not comfortable
doing it no not me not me being on a set
I feel very very shy well you are gonna
go on this edit big little eyes when
Meryl is there or have you been already
yeah you already when she's shooting
yeah how is that going
so yeah it's so good I mean she's just
amazing and and to watch her do her
craft and it really is like artistic
craft when you watch her and we're all
laura dern Shailene Zoe Reese we just go
oh can you believe it really cuz you
know you guys are huge stars in your own
right so do you really though but you
look at Meryl everybody doesn't look at
Meryl go Wow yeah yeah and she's got a
fantastic character so it's also you
know it's it's grounded and it's based
in something very very real and we hope
we bring you the second season
deliver so I know it I know it will I
understand you're a Meryl fan - are you
who isn't thin you're a big one right
yeah big thing I love that she's joined
this crazy cast and this incredible big
little eyes so I've seen little bits and
pieces of it already and it's amazing
anything you can like tease us about
both okay yeah
that's figurative and literal in this
case right with HBO's got it yeah I know
that you're uncomfortable on his head
but would you ever do a cameo I mean
comfortable I wouldn't go on camera I
love being on the set where Nick is bad
I want to be on camera that's what I
mean would you ever do a cameo or
anything rather be in the studio Meryl
doesn't singing you could do something
for the soundtrack I know yes
you got a soundtrack just amongst the
cast and your husband
you